سلمت السلطات الاسرائيليه للاردن النائبه
الاردنيه عماد العدوان بعد اعتقاله لنحو
اسبوعين بتهمه تهريب اسلحه الى الضفه
الغربيه وقال بيان صادر عن جهاز الامن
الاسرائيلي العام المعروف بالشباك ان
التحقيقات اظهرت ان العدوان نفذ منذ شباط
فبراير من العام الماضي اثنتي عشره عمليه
تهريب لم تقتصر على الاسلحه مستغلا بذلك
جواز سفره الدبلوماسي واضاف ان السلطات
الاسرائيليه عثرت في مركبته على اكثر من
200 قطعه سلاح وانها اعتقلت فلسطينيين من
الضفه الغربيه اتهمتهم بالتورط في عمليه
تهريب الاسلحه مع العدوان ظهرت التحقيقات
ان هدف العدوان كان ماديا نحو انه تلقى
مبالغ ماليه طائله لقاء ذلك
وذكرت مصادر اسرائيليه مسؤوله ان الافراج
عن العدوان جاء بعد اتفاق بين جهاز تشابك
وجهاز المخابرات الاردنيه العام يقضي
باعتقال العدوان ومحاكمته في الاردن
ان عمليه تسليم النائب عماد العدوان من
طرف اسرائيل الى الاردن بدات على جسر
الملك حسين وقال رئيس مجلس نواب الاردني
احمد الصفدي العدوان دخل الحدود الاردنيه
وتم رفع الحصانه عنه بطلب من نيابه محكمه
امن الدوله الاردنيه
دعنا من امام مجلس النواب الاردنيه في
عمان مدير مكتب الجزيره حسن الشوبكي حسن
اهلا بك اذا نود ان اعرف المزيد حول ظروف
تسليم العدوان للاردن هل تم الكشف عن
تفاصيل مضمون هذا الاتفاق بين الجانبين
الاسرائيلي والاردن
نعم سفيان يعني ما يمكن قوله ان المجلس
النواب الاغلبيه
صوت لرفع الحصانه عن النائب عماد العدوان
في جلسه سريه جرت قبل نحو ساعه في هذه
الجلسه قام رئيس مجلس النواب احمد الصفدي
يعني
جعل هذه الجلسه سريه خرجت الحكومه وخرجت
ايضا وسائل الاعلام وقام النواب بالاغلبيه
بالتصويت لرفع الحصانه عن
النائب عماد العدوان طبعا هذا رفع الحصانه
هذا تم بعد ان جاء بطلب من نيابه امن
الدوله التي تسلمت النائب العدوان وستبدا
التحقيق معه في بعد التحقيقات التي جرت له
في اسرائيل هذا ما صرح به احمد الصفدي
رئيس مجلس النواب قبل قليل في عجاله وكذلك
الناطق باسم الخارجيه الاردنيه السف
المجالي قال انه اجراءات تسليم النائب
عماد العدوان تمت قبل نحو ساعه عبر جسر
الملك حسين بين الاردن واسرائيل وهذا
الامر قد تم بالفعل هذا من الطرف الاردني
لا يوجد اي اضاحات او تفصيلات يعني جرى مع
العدوان في اسرائيل اما بالنسبه لما بيان
الشابات جهاز الامن الاسرائيلي قال ان
النائب العدوان قام بالتهريب منذ شهر
فبراير الماضي بنحو 12 مره وان هنالك يعني
من ضلع معه في عمليات التهريب هذه وان
هنالك اعتقالات من طرف المخابرات الاردنيه
لعدد ممن يعني كانوا معه هذا وفقا لما جاء
في بيان الشباك بيان الشباك ايضا قال انه
ضبط نحو 200 قطعه سلاح في سيارته بالاضافه
الى تهريبه اشياء اخرى بهدف مادي كما قالت
قال جهاز الامن الاسرائيلي ان الهدف كان
ماديا بالنسبه
للنائب العدوان وقال ان هنالك تهريب
لاشياء اخرى مثل سيجاره الكترونيه وتهريب
ايضا حيوانات كما ورد بيان الشباك قبل
قليل اشكرك يا حسن الشوبكي كنت معنا من
عمان